hey youtubers is Charlie so whole bunch
of new Doctor Strange multiverse teasing
footage so I combined it with some Thor
Avengers clips to kind of build out the
way the MCU is explaining all this stuff
so here we go Doctor Strange what if I
told you the reality you know is one of
many that doesn't make any sense
not everything does not everything has
to
through the mystic arts
harness energy
and shape reality
there's a strength to it
but is he ready
the devil which pass your travel down
stranger
the new who have passed away
I can't do this there is no other way
dr. strained your work saved the lives
of thousands what if I told you that
reality is one of many
other ways to save lives I've spent so
many years hearing full-time looking to
you Steven strength
forget everything that you think you
know you wonder what I see in your
future possibility
these are ready
there is no other way
Stephen strange might I offer you some
advice forget everything that you think
you know there's a strength to them
where these are you ready the careful
which paths you travel downstream
stronger men by Buckner way I can't do
this there is no other way so what's
this my mantra
the Wi-Fi hustling we're not savages so
the big idea like the operating word is
other realities they're talking about
other dimensions talking about the
multiverse so Doctor Strange is like a
movie is obviously introducing magic
into the Marvel Universe in a really big
way like official magic Loki uses magic
but the way he uses it looks a little
bit more like illusion even though in
the comics he's an actual magic user dr.
strange is going to give you that Thor
moment from like the first Thor film
where he's talking to Jane Foster and
she's trying to prove the theory behind
the Rainbow Bridge wormholes quantum
tunneling quantum fields so magic the
gods are just science that you have not
explained yet so even though there is
magic in Doctor Strange they're going to
give you that type of explanation
because one of the other big quotes in
this one of the big takeaways is we
manipulate energy so there is an energy
source that they draw upon to create
their magic so we've been talking about
Dormammu the Dark Dimension that's
really just like one of many dimensions
it's just kind of like what they might
use is like the cancer verse in the MCU
like the darkest timeline universe so
Doctor Strange is going to introduce all
these complex ideas and make it seem
really simple really cool but it's also
you know further the characters like
within the universe like Tony Stark man
of science is going to kind of wake him
up to those possibilities and I a kid
just can't wait for dr. strange to meet
Tony Stark remember the scene where he
was trying to lift Thor's hammer he's
like I think the saying goes whoever has
the fingerprints of Thor like he always
tries to find the scientific explanation
for any situation but it's a trick no no
it's much more than that whosoever be he
worthy shall haveth up and whatever man
it's a trick please be my guest come on
really yeah
this is going to be beautiful and you've
had a tough week we won't hold it
against you if you can't get it up seems
before you do no silent judgment please
start by all means okay mm-hmm never one
to shrink from an honest challenge get
out
it's physics good all right so what if I
lift it I then rule Asgard yes of course
i will be reinstituting prima nocta
Birkbeck even pulley are you on my team
just represent pull all right let's go
Steve no pressure
come on cap
hmm and Widow oh no no that's not a
question I need answered
all deference to the man who wouldn't be
king but it's Rick you bet your ass
Steve he said a bad language word you
tell everyone about the head owes
imprinted right like a security code
whosoever is carrying Thor's
fingerprints is I think the literal
translation yes that's uh it's a very
very interesting theory I have a simpler
one you're all not worthy the thing is
there is a scientific explanation it's
just that you know within the stuff that
the characters have done so far in the
movies they haven't gotten to that level
of knowledge yet where they have a more
complex understanding of existence so
Doctor Strange is the guy that's been
studying this whole time to learn about
that so he's gonna be the one to
introduce all these characters to that
but the other thing I think we've
settled on is the idea of the time gem
being in his eye of agamotto just like
that green glowy thing in the middle
here you don't really see it too well in
the footage but it does look like this
moment here like with all the sparks
flying around and [ __ ] going crazy that
this is from a big action set piece so
this might be him using the time gem to
defeat you know whatever the true
villain of the movie is going to be
whether it be cassellius Maz Mickelson's
character who's trying to collapse all
the dimensions into one dimension or
maybe something even bigger like
Dormammu or the Shuma gorath or
something really crazy but make no
mistake this movie might seem like a
really weird character just kind of
getting his day in the Sun in the way
that Ant Man did I can't man is kind of
a funny character but it turned into
this great small Marvel movie it wasn't
super grand like an Avengers movie or a
Captain America Civil War but it was
still really interesting this Doctor
Strange movie is much closer to that
really grand type of Avengers movie
while still being kind of small and
self-contained because a lot of the
stuff that's happening during Doctor
Strange is also going on concurrently
with all the stuff that's been happening
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 they haven't
completely explained the timeline but
they do say the Doctor Strange has been
in training this whole time which is why
he wasn't around to recap tanam Erica
Civil War why he wasn't around during
the shatori invasion to help
out because that's a really big deal
like sheet re invasion if he really was
sorcerer supreme unless he was busy in
some other dimension fighting some even
bigger villain he would have helped out
but there was this big press conference
that Marvel had recently where they
invited a bunch of press outlets to ask
them questions about the Marvel Universe
the movies that they're working on in
Bob Iger Disney person revealed that
they're starting to have talks about the
movies in phase four and Beyond now that
that's no surprise like everybody knows
that Marvel plans way down the road
they've been developing all kinds of
characters and scripts that they think
might be really good based on the
direction they want to go after infinity
war because what you do Infinity
Gauntlet
you can't just reboot and do the exact
same thing you kind of change the nature
of the way the movies work the big
overarching villains we've talked about
Dormammu and the more supernatural
villains of the Marvel Universe kind of
taking the stage after Thanos has his
day in the Sun so Doctor Strange the
movie is not only important for Marvel
and that it wants to introduce this
really big character to the Avengers
so that it can do this big infinity war
storyline it's also important it's like
a big test for what's going to be coming
in phase 4 after infinity war is done
because there's a certain amount of
revenue that you can bank on with the
characters that you have now people will
always go down for a Captain America
movie people love Robert Downey jr.
people love the idea Santos the Infinity
Gauntlet but after that the real
question is is like can Marvel maintain
this momentum so while I think the movie
is going to be awesome Doctor Strange is
also a pretty big risk much bigger risk
I think than ant-man because if ant-man
had done poorly they would have been
like okay you know we'll like and we'll
include him in infinity war in a real
small way we just won't do a sequel but
the conceit behind Doctor Strange the
character the movie is so important it's
like the foundation of what's going to
be happening after phase 3 is over so
it's just like okay we really want this
to do well but let me know in the
comments do you think the Doctor Strange
is going to be like the cornerstone of
Marvel in phase 4 going forward like the
supernatural more otherworldly things
inside the Marvel Universe because
unless you push into more crazy things
in the Marvel Universe
you just end up recycling the same ideas
over and over
over again so it becomes diminishing
returns so Marvel isn't just thinking
about the next four or five years it's
thinking about the next 15 to 20 years
they get hype it's gonna be awesome if
you guys haven't seen I've been doing
Ghost Rider videos for agents of shield
so the Ghost Rider supernatural stuff on
agents of shield this season will tie in
with what's happening in the Doctor
Strange movie so if you haven't been
watching agents of shield I'd actually
recommend that you start they've only
had the first episode episode 2 is next
week I'm doing videos for the entire
season it is way more badass than it's
been in the past and I'm still doing the
Captain America Civil War giveaway so
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video what I'm probably gonna do next is
some Justice League movie stuff there's
been some pretty cool stuff that's been
happening lately so that will post later
tonight will you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all
about the Punisher iron fist defenders
crossover and you can click here to
watch the last big flash trailer I just
post it thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight